today after a Kentucky Chamber of
Commerce meeting Mitch McConnell was set
to speak at a small press conference and
it happened
again what are your thoughts on running
for re-election in 2026 what are my
thoughts about what running for
reelection in
2026 did you hear the question Senator
running for re-election in 2026
yes
all right I'm sorry you all we're going
to need a
minute Senator Benny
Y
headside come with
us
okay somebody else have a question
please speak up well no he's not okay
now bizar Bly after that disturbing
episode neither of the two questions
that followed reference what just
happened but this was the final question
what is your reaction on Trump's latest
indictment and would you support him as
a nominee it's a question about
Trump yeah I'm not going to comment
about the presidential race e either on
the Republican side or the Democrat
side McConnell spokesman tried to
explain all this away saying that m felt
momentarily laded and paused during that
press conference now that's not what we
saw this is a
pause we have real problems here in both
parties our government is about to begin
what are monumentally important
negotiations over the budget and
Appropriations five men are supposed to
play a dominant role in those talks
Biden is 80 years old Schumer 72
McConnell 81 and McCarthy hakee Jeff
both in their 50s now this means at
least two of those five involved in
deciding how we spend trillions of our
tax
dollars they're no longer capable of
working full-time and both sadly show
obvious symptoms of serious physical and
cognitive
decline now this is always a tough
situation in any family but in this case
with the authority and the power that
they have I have no words for their
wives and families who keep pushing them
out there oh wait a second wait a second
that's right Jill's not a doctor a real
one so she can't diagnose Biden's
obvious
deterioration now I will yield to who am
I yielding
to distinguished guest the president of
the Republic of
Korea we needed the voice of God to tell
us
that neither McConnell nor Biden should
be in their current jobs we all know
that and given everything we know about
the foreign money Trail Biden is likely
compromised not just by his health but
by the millions and millions his family
has made overseas so being corrupt is
bad being corrupt and scile is even
worse and as for Senator McConnell he
should be at home enjoying his Twilight
years he did some really good stuff with
Supreme Court nominations and he should
get credit for that but every member of
the Republican conference should have
compassionately urged him to step aside
5 weeks ago which is the last time when
this happened the fact that no one did
this least to our knowledge is stunning
and frankly
irresponsible of course as angle has
noted previously the Democrats they're
only going to dump Biden if they think
he's become a political liability they
haven't thought that yet remember they
actually prefer having a puppet like
Biden as president because he's easily
manipulated
but Republicans can't finstein McConnell
in other words let him continue on like
this it's cruel and it also negates
their ability to make Biden's own
decrepit State an issue in
2024 and by the way whomever the GOP
Senate chooses to replace McConnell
should not be his establishment under
study instead he or she should reflect
the majority views of the party on China
on the border on the Deep State the need
to reform it Ukraine and
trade as I said the other night we've
already won the debate on the big issues
in the GOP and there's no going back to
2005 kids hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else